Now that we understand what an operating system is, we can ask ourselves,
what are some examples of actual operating systems?
The examples of real systems out there differ based on the environment that
they target.
For instance, certain operating systems target more of
the desktop environment o.r the server environment.
Others target more of the embedded environment.
Yet another set of operating systems target ultra high end
machines like mainframes.
But we'll focus on these environments, the desktop and
embedded in our discussions just because they're most common.
And also with these examples we'll really focus on more recent, more
current really operating systems, as opposed to those that have been around or
that have evolved over the last 60 plus years of computer science.
For desktop operating systems one of the very popular ones is Microsoft Windows.
It is been a well-known operating system since the early 1980s.
Next there's a family of operating systems that extended from
the operating system that originated at Bell Labs in the late 1960s, and
these are all referred to as UNIX-based operating systems.
This involves the Mac OS X operating system for
Apple devices, and this extends the UNIX BSD kernel, and
BSD here is really Berkley System Distribution of Unix.
And Linux is another very popular UNIX like system, and
it is open sourced, and it comes bundled with many popular software libraries.
There are in fact many different versions of Linux.
Ubuntu, CentOS, etc.
On the embedded side, we've recently seen bigger proliferation of different
operating systems, just because of the rising number of smartphones and
user devices, like tablet's, and now even smaller form factor devices.
First you're probably very familiar with Android.
It's an embedded form of Linux that runs on many of these types of devices.
And its versions come with funny names like Ice Cream Sandwich and KitKat.
Next we have iOS and that's the, Apple proprietary operating system for
devices like iPhones and iPads.
Then there is Symbian, and then there are other less population options.
In each of these operating systems there are a number of unique choices in their
design and
implementation, and in this class we will particularly focus on Linux.
So the majority of more illustrative,
more in-depth examples will be given based on the Linux operating system.